自慢じゃないけど
今日2時間しか寝てないて今月の初め社長です
なんとなく株から伝わればいいと思うんですけどもう今すぐ出たいんだしかし今日は
やらなきゃいけないこともあるとって寝れないんですよね今なんですけどちょっと子鹿
がありますいま何で神青したいですぼくぼくカミオシ体でも仮眠よして今桁沸騰したら
そのんでちゃうかもしれない8ねぇんではないですけどこんな回近く時間
がっつり寝ちゃうかもしれないけど1時間だけでたいっていうタイミングなぁ
ナンですですねぼく目覚まし時計で常に思っていたことがあるんですけども
いいいい
本当にうるさいと思いません皆さんも各目覚まし時計ねちゃんと時間にをてやればいい
んですけども大人部作と不快なんですよねやっぱりその時に皆さん不快にならずに
起きれる目覚まし時計があるのをご存じでしょうかこっちだ
こちらブライトアップクロック数開けてみましょう
うわぁなる細いぞこれ時計ですよつだけもう
うわーっすげーなーほんとにこんな感じになっておりますそれちょっとこと気になっ
てるでしょ
こんな感じになっておりますそれ何かと言いますと最近話題になっている光目覚ましい
特恵述べ
ジャックちゃ強い奴がございますネットで色々調べた結果俺が光の強さもめちゃくちゃ
強いだして会長の光目覚まし時計らしいですって光目指す退けて何かと言いますと
目指しを受けて基本的に音で鳴らすんですけれどもこれは光や音が遊べるみたいで
ございますだからうるさくないから光だけで行
[音楽]
身近な感じを受けるのかちょっとよくわかんない人よくわかんないんですけどなんか
そんなイメージです僕の中では1回つけてみようか落ちちゃった次いでついたん
だあああああああ
もう眩し眩しいこれを待ってこれまさか
俺いけるわこれ
[音楽]
くしゃみが出るぞすごいと僕太陽の光でし格差にできないと思うんですけどこれ強すぎ
てこれで元ミク者にできるよってすごいなぁいいだけで今からこれを使って髪をしよう
と思うんですけども
[音楽]
うっ
うっだったスタッフなっ
あっ
[音楽]
寝不足の僕はこんなんじゃあ起きませんということで今回服こちらの光目覚まし時計
たくさん準備しましたら10個寸日しました今ある僕カミウして多分起きないってもう
このまま今日は寝ようと思ってるんですけども果たしてこの大量な光目指し時を一気に
つけるとどれぐらいのしっかりの強さになるのかを光が強すぎてひょっとしてはもう
なんかもうどうなるかほんと計り知れないけど
広陵が寝てる僕を襲い米に来ると思うので今回ですね僕はに今から寝て大量の光目指す
時計のパワーをこの身をもって体感してみたいと思いますおやすみ
th
はいちゃけど全部セットできましたあのー多いたところの感想
なか電力が凄そうですねひょっとしたらこれって5区前に家が停電したんじゃない
かっていう可能性が出てきました今ちょっと時間が設定していきます
[音楽]
ん
はいという意味で無事光目の場所だけで全部設定完了しましたちょっとさんは目覚まし
が鳴るで僕ちょっとガッツリ今から仮眠します果たして最強の光目覚まし時計の威力
どれほどのモードか
かかって来い地球の民がーる上でてねー
[音楽]
rar
を
[音楽]
んああああ
[拍手]
してもらうぜまずは卸えっ
立っ
car
uh
うううう
car
me
範囲というわけですげーなーなんかすぐまぶしってさん死ぬかと思ったんですけど
ぜひ爺ってうるさくないから比較的だの木持つ受けられた方だと思います
うるさい目指しまこれでしたらひょっとしたら快適に遅れるかもしれませんね
ぜひ使ってみてはいかがでしょうかおやすみ